Gregg is in Nashville
hi Gregg how are you Todd doing well how
about Stealth better than I deserve
what's up I guess we've been people s
with couple good jobs in all their lives
and I have a little girl now she's
actually been in a transition her job
which is a really good job thing that's
not too well but we've also been the
other side for anything it'd be good or
not for her to just quit and get
stay-at-home mom for a while and we just
want to know what your thoughts were if
it was feasible with our incomes yeah I
think it's a wonderful idea
if that's what she wants to do can you
live on your income yes what do you make
right at 80,000 years okay you guys have
had no student loans are paid well
through their car sort of phase for
about 50,000 I don't pay our house okay
very good
what does she make at the moment she I'd
say she's probably right at about 24 she
left a job earlier in the year I found
out at 50 mm-hmm I kind of started a
part-time internship but it's just kind
of one of those things with a little
girls you know - and she's really
thinking it we want to have a little bit
more time at the house with her yeah at
the same times you've never been not in
fully declare she's very scared about
not having a job well I mean the thing
is this what the it sounds like she
wants to be at home but she feels like
it's her duty to work is that what
you're telling me I believe so yes yeah
I think she ought to be home I agree
words of wisdom all houses pray that we
make enough money we've done a good
enough job with our finances we're
debt-free we can live on my income
let's sit down and look at the budget
what it looks like on my check and we'll
work on that together and I think this
is your desire I also think this lady
the way you're describing her will
probably go back to work when the child
goes into school at some point percent
correct yeah I just think that she's
wired that way I think she gets
something out of the workplace and I
think it's something she'll want to
return to but you don't have to though
it's not a requirement um you know and
it but but there's a lot of economic
benefits for mom being in the home
full-time lots of them I mean you know
she cooks from scratch it saves money
it's healthier you know the kids are you
know subjected to other kids and only as
you want them to be and in healthy
situations and so you know there's all
kinds of stuff that happens when moms at
home it's all good and it's all good
it's good for the kid it's good for
everybody but it's not doesn't mean
you're bad mom if you're not at home
it's not at all what we're saying but
this lady wants to be at home so she
should be at home it's just as simple I
mean to me and my wife is the same way
her goal in life was being mom and 32
years ago she became full-time mom and
our 33 years ago now I guess but on when
Denise was born and had has not worked
outside the home since and and frankly
we're empty nesters and obviously we
don't need any money but you know even
if she wanted to go do something I would
really don't one or two because I'm
comfortable about her being there and
our schedule is pretty free we could
just do whatever we want to do and I
don't have to stop and ask somebody else
if I want call vacation because I own
the freaking place down here I can go
when I want so you know it's just it's a
matter of that kind of stuff this is why
you work so that you get to choose when
you work and how you work and you can
choose what your career path is and you
wow you're good with money while you're
good financially so that you can choose
all these things and that that's the
process
so I I don't know how you talked her
into it but I think you're gonna have to
talk her into I think she wants to be
there with that baby and she's not doing
anything wrong there's no higher calling
than motherhood I mean really nine